February 2019 will see a ton of new Netflix
content, with exciting new releases in every
major genre.
We've rounded up the best of the best to showcase
everything great coming to Netflix in February
2019.
Natasha Lyonne of Orange Is the New Black
produced and stars in Russian Doll, a series
about a woman forced to relive the night of
a big party over and over again, an experience
which is always rudely interrupted by her
death.
Forget the obvious similarity to Happy Death
Day; the always-entertaining Lyonne told The
Hollywood Reporter
"It's an autobiography wrapped in a mind-bending
concept.
I'm 100 percent in there and most definitely
the architect of the whole thing."
This show not only sports a deadpan sense
of humor, but has the potential to get very
interesting very quickly, and the first season
drops on February 1st.
The third feature from Nightcrawler director
Dan Gilroy reunites him with that amazing
film's lead actors Jake Gyllenhaal and Rene
Russo, along with John Malkovich and Toni
Collette.
It's the story of a Soho art gallery owner
and a vicious critic who come into possession
of the works of an artist whose recent death
is shrouded in mystery… and they soon wish
they hadn't.
"It's connected to his art!"
The flick's insane trailer promises a mind-bending
ride, a committed performance from Gyllenhaal,
and a bunch of profoundly creepy imagery.
This is Gilroy's first foray into flat-out
horror, and you can give it a watch on February
1st.
The Finnish detective series Bordertown was
picked up for international distribution by
Netflix after its debut season, which went
on to strike a chord with streaming audiences
with its dark, compelling storytelling.
Fans of shows like The Killing and True Detective
will find Bordertown to be a treat; when the
first episode of season 1 aired on Finnish
television, it was watched by over a million
viewers.
If you haven't checked out the first batch
of episodes, you may want to catch up before
season 2 drops on February 2nd.
Screenwriter Tarell Alvin McCraney picked
up an Oscar for co-scripting the 2016 Best
Picture winner Moonlight.
For his next trick, he's giving us High Flying
Bird, a fictionalized account of the efforts
of a sports agent to salvage the careers of
his clients in the wake of the real-life 2011
NBA lockout.
Oh, and in the director's chair is Steven
Soderbergh, whose recent successes include
Logan Lucky and the psychological thriller
Unsane.
The sports drama is scoring big time with
critics; you can give it a shot when it premieres
on February 8th.
The Break is a Belgian series which follows
the attempt of a veteran police detective
to escape from his demons by returning to
his peaceful, relatively murder-free hometown.
But things take a turn for the worse when
a body is discovered, leading our protagonist
down a sinister path.
The first season was well-received by critics
who appreciated its bleak cinematography and
snappy, well-written dialogue; the noir-ish
drama makes its return with season 2 on February
9th.
Daily Show veteran Hasan Minaj made a splash
with the first season of his insightful political
comedy series Patriot Act, in which he explores
topics relevant to today's society through
the filter of his unique comedic sensibility.
Each episode focuses on a single topic, which
Minhaj delves into through a combination of
standup, interviews, and on location segments.
Minhaj's cutting yet thoughtful brand of political
humor is perhaps something we can all use
more of right now, and season 2 of Patriot
Act will give us just that when it drops on
February 10th.
The Breaker Upperers is a comedy film from
New Zealand with Thor: Ragnarok director involved
as an executive producer.
"Look at this world, amazement!
What’s through this door?
Oh Australia."
Sami and Jackie van Beek, directors of The
Breaker Upperers, came into Waititi's orbit
when they appeared as actors in his features
What We Do in the Shadows and Eagle versus
Shark.
In addition to directing, the pair also star
as cynical friends who go into business breaking
up couples for profit.
"I'm sorry Jeff, it's over"
"What?"
The film scored with critics when it made
the festival rounds, and it'll likely score
with you when it hits the small screen on
February 15th.
Based on a Dark Horse comic book series created
by Gerard Way, the original series The Umbrella
Academy follows a group of children with otherworldly
powers who were all born simultaneously on
the same day in 1989.
Brought together in their teen years by a
mysterious billionaire, they all regroup 17
years later upon their benefactor's death
in an attempt to get to the bottom of the
events surrounding his passing.
Get ready for superpowered intrigue when the
first season drops on February 15th.
This violent period piece from Korea explores
the rise of a petty crook from Busan who ups
his game by diving into the Asian narcotics
trade of the 1970's.
Eventually, he becomes - you guessed it - a
drug king, struggling to hold his place atop
his organization while pouring a steady stream
of contraband into Japan and keeping up a
front as a benevolent community leader.
Look for it on February 21.
Paddleton is the sophomore feature from director
Alex Lehmann, and stars co-writer Mark Duplass
alongside Ray Romano as odd couple neighbors
who develop an unlikely friendship.
Their bond is quickly put to the test, however,
when one of them receives a terminal cancer
diagnosis.
The flick absolutely wowed critics on the
festival circuit, with Romano's performance
in particular being singled out for praise.
"What's the worst case scenario we run out
of gas?"
"Worst case scenario is we run out of gas
right here and next thing you know, we’re
drinking our urine."
You'll definitely want to check out Paddleton
when it makes its streaming debut on February
22.
There's more than meets the eye to the French
drama Paris is Us, the story of a young woman
who returns to her home city.
The trailer promises a blurring of the lines
between fantasy and reality, as our heroine
begins to draw parallels between her traumatic
recent past and events in the world at large.
"It's now that everything is possible, even
if this life may be just a dream."
The Kickstarter funded project was shot between
2014 and 2017 before being picked up by Netflix.
Paris has not been resting easy as of late,
and this incorporates some real-world tension
into its rather trippy narrative.
You can check it out on February 22nd.
Suburra is a gritty Italian crime series centered
on a seaside town near Rome, which various
interested parties have designs on turning
into a gambling resort.
Coming into conflict with each other over
these plans are a prominent Roman family,
a slew of corrupt politicians, the Catholic
church, and the Mafia.
The series' first season drew favorable comparisons
with The Wire, and was widely praised for
its stark tone and thriller-esque pacing.
Profane, raw, and violent, it's been called
"the kind of show that grabs your attention
and doesn't let go" - perfect for binge-watching.
Season 2 premieres on February 22.
Those are all the best Netflix originals showing
up in February, but there's plenty more to
look forward to!
There are a few choice selections for thriller
fans in February, most notably the first installment
of the long-running Final Destination series.
That arrives with the entirety of the Jaws
franchise, from Steven Spielberg's benchmark-setting
original to Jaws: The Revenge, a feature that
regularly winds up in discussion of the worst
films of all time.
"Damn passengers are all the same, complain
complain.
Oh snap!"
Those show up on the first, alongside a number
of beloved comedies.
Starting this month, look for the warm Hugh
Grant vehicle About a Boy and the first three
American Pie movies.
Later in the month, Steve Carell's breakout
film The 40-Year Old Virgin arrives on the
16th, followed by the comedy-drama Our Idiot
Brother on the 26th.
"Come in."
Only a pair of new drama offerings are making
their way to Netflix this month, but they're
both well worth a watch.
2016's The Edge of Seventeen features burgeoning
star Hailee Steinfeld in a thoughtful coming-of-age
drama and drops on the first.
And on the sixth, look for 2009's The Soloist
starring Robert Downey, Jr. as a newspaper
columnist who becomes unlikely friends with
a blind violinist played by Jamie Foxx.
Finally, Netflix is premiering three new original
comedy specials in February.
On the fifth, Ray Romano returns to New York's
famed Comedy Cellar after 23 years to deliver
a new standup set in Right Here, Around the
Corner.
Kevin Hart examines the contributions of African
Americans through his uniquely cracked lens
in a new special available on the 8th.
And the hilarious Ken Jeong delivers a Valentine's
Day set of silliness in his first Netflix
special on the 14th.
"You can't do that."
"Have you met me?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.